by now we've covered almost all of
evolves hunter classes in GameSpot's
next big game coverage of turtle rocks
asymmetrical multiplayer shooter all
except one
so what exactly does the support class
bring to the table a little bit of
everything as it turns out where other
classes tend to specialize in one major
endeavor the support class can deal
damage corral the monster and help
allies out in a pinch even if it means
ripping off your own head for the good
of the team no bucket isn't some
suicidal Berserker it's a robot
detaching your head isn't just a morale
booster though it does have a certain
anatomical whimsy to it once removed
buckets head becomes an airborne UAV
that you pile it around the cavernous
environs of the planet shear in order to
locate your quarry get the monster in
your decapitated sights for a few
seconds and a kind of tracking lock-on
will kick in and set automatic way
points of the monsters position for all
your teammates to see going headless
does leave your body vulnerable and
stationary so it can be risky but if you
don't have Maggie the trapars monster
sniffing sidekick along it's one of the
best ways of scouting the level for a
flying Leviathan once you've got a bead
on the Beast it's time to start sending
a message nothing says we're on your
tail you tentacled freak like a harrying
barrage of laser-guided rockets
generally speaking any damage to the
monster is good damage but with an enemy
as mobile as the Kraken long-distance
shots can act like a whip driving your
prey before you this could be a bad idea
if it Spurs the monster on and farther
out of range or it could be a strategic
master stroke if you use the missile
blasts to steer the Beast within range
of your trappers mobile arena you crafty
little robot you when the dome goes up
and it's going down bucket gives birth
from within your cold metallic carapace
you discharge a litter of hovering Auto
turrets group of you together preferably
near a clutch of harpoon mines and
create a damaging field of fire to put
the Whammy on the monster or perch a few
on nearby ledges to deny your prey safe
refuge once a bunch of your mini
are in play get the Missal train running
again pausing only occasionally to
replace the turrets that have been
snuffed out with these two offensive
abilities Buckett can make the monsters
life much more chaotic chaos leads to
anger anger leads to hate hate leads to
maybe you'd better disappear real quick
because that monster is this fortunately
you've got this nifty area cloaking
ability that turns you and any nearby
Ally invisible it's good for escaping
the monsters wrath good for assisting
with friendly revives good for hiding
and laying an ambush for the monster
really it's just generally good at
supporting all of the hunters endeavors
just like everyone's favorite support
robot it may not have a beating heart
but it's unlikely the team would survive
without bucket